i'm just eating for fun i'm just
stuffing my face because it's really
good
[Music]
hi guys i'm matt a tasty
producer and here at tasty we know a
thing or two about fried chicken so
today i'm going to be comparing one of
our homemade recipes to that of a
popular chain restaurant
so i'm just going to prep my station and
get started
i had never made fried chicken before
i'd always wanted to but assumed it was
too difficult so i figured this would be
a great opportunity to learn how i
practiced by making a few batches for my
friends one weekend and the first few
were a bit crispy but eventually i was
able to get the hang of it
something i really love about making
your own fried chicken is the freedom
you have to customize the flavors you
can change the herbs and spices to
whatever you'd like
[Music]
if you like a thicker crust dip the
chicken back into the buttermilk brine
and re-coat in the seasoned flour
frying in the oil was what intimidated
me the most but once i figured out what
the right temperatures were it became
much easier than i anticipated
if the oil is too cold you'll end up
with soggy breading if it's too hot the
outside will burn while the inside stays
raw
[Music]
i was stoked with how it looked but i
had to see how people thought it tasted
this was really good you can see how
golden brown it is this is really
excellent actually i like this a lot the
skin on this is crispy it's really well
seasoned got a lot more depth to it it's
not just straight salty this feels like
it's homemade i love fast food fried
chicken it's quick and inexpensive but
always satisfying great for when you're
in a rush or just don't feel like
cooking oh it's warm it's a little bit
greasy kooby popeyes or something nice
and savory meats tender tastes like
classic
fried chicken pretty basic fried chicken
but
it's also fried chicken therefore it
tastes good overall i think both
versions are great the fast food fried
chicken was the cheaper one by a long
shot while the chicken for the homemade
wasn't too expensive i had to buy
gallons of oil and a pot that was safe
for frying in and the cost just kind of
added up the fast food was much quicker
than making it at home in the time it
took my chicken to brine i was able to
drive to and from the restaurant and eat
my entire order the homemade does give
you the most creative freedom i was able
to fiddle around with the seasonings i
used whereas at the restaurant i was
locked into whatever options were on
their menu
while my taste testers preferred the
homemade version the fast food version
nailed the nostalgia factor tasting just
as good as they remembered ultimately i
think both are awesome the fast food
fried chicken was just as satisfying and
as easy as i remembered the homemade
took a bit more effort but i was able to
tweak the flavors and crunchiness to
exactly how i prefer them you really
can't go wrong either way
hello
my job control marsh
today we're going to be doing asmr fried
chicken
[Music]
you